he okay he came in here without that
jacket on yeah he that baby just had a
Pampa on all he got
on I
can't yeah don't do that all right so
those confused there's a
kid in some trash bags mhm shivering
they're in the Frozen aisle and he's
shivering and the is shaking and under
the garbage bag is nothing but a diaper
it's nothing but a
diaper I saw this earlier but looking
back at it now was still crazy and look
at how she's dressed so she's dressed in
Boots full pullover and everyone around
has seen this right the other black FES
seen this like excuse me yo put that kid
in clothes what he's she's shaking
they're filming this so other Good
Samaritans are like this isn't right
yeah don't do that somebody call police
what's wrong with you somebody call
police
on get out that get out that man face
please
crazy no way
bro bro that is the most remember that
[__] I told you about we told yall last
time Americans sometimes will just start
twerking for no reason remember that
[__] I told you about it is actually
insane you'll be just talking to
somebody for no reason unprovoked
twerking I call it there's not a beat
there's not nothing the amount of Y the
amount of fatherless activity happening
on screen all at once is
nasty that is
nasty what the hell some to call police
on her go ahead already been called two
times I keep pass long you got hot water
fire extinguisher
but when you come in the sto full of
dress in your baby's not now call cop
right now how many kids do you get I got
one
okay is that the new level is that the
new level you know before people their
parents and you say something you have
any kids nah n n that don't talk you
wouldn't understand now it's how many
kids one oh you wouldn't understand cuz
you only tried this [__] one time how
you going to tell me with my multiple
kids are clearly
succeeding how you going to tell me
anything how many kids you got how many
kids don't say nothing about how many
kids how many kids say it say the number
say it say it say it you got an opinion
say it how many kids how many kids I got
no kids yeah so maybe you should have no
opinions either yeah no kids no thoughts
that's a good bar that's a good bar and
you just created that yeah yeah yeah
yeah now people are going people are
going to use your bar and they're going
to say AB at it yeah there's a lot of
people too they watch you know they be
like AB preach y kid y'all can't say
nothing I bet you a lot of them are
agreeing with us right now what happened
I thought we had no opinion I thought
people who don't have kids can't have an
opinion about kids now you want to agree
with us listen I don't think this
is listen you can't even keep your
composure I hate I hate when people with
kids be like you would understand no no
yeah it's okay maybe I don't understand
all the minute details of and proceed to
do the
[__] your kids in [__] diapers in a
trash bag I'm calling the cops 100% I
don't care how much like you don't have
no kids you don't understand I'm calling
the [__] cops instantly 100% that kid
is shaking like literally he could be on
death's door and you not even realize it
he could go into shock at any point he
can get extremely at that age they're
[Music]
vulnerable all and the C they're in the
Frozen no no she's crazy as an adult as
an adult with clothes like when I go in
the Frozen ey I get cold sometimes 100%
100 it's a baby in a trash bag and
sometime and sometimes the doors are
closed and I'm cold yes I'm the doors
are [__] cold and I'm dressed
this is a big refrigerator aisle that's
a lot of refrigeration is natural to be
cold there yeah and nothing but a diaper
because let's be honest let's be honest
let's be honest that plastic bag ain't
doing [__] for the baby let's let's be
honest so he's in nothing but a diaper
and no shoes might I add n no shoes this
what H say take that kid away but the
fact that she said go ahead call CPS as
long as you got hot water it really goes
to show you I know take take the you can
get a lot with a lot when it comes to
hurting
children she just sad that just
sad come on
man
while the girl while while the lady the
lady is just standing there letting
another another letting another
bystander put some [__] on
her you
good let me
stretch you about to reach what's up no
I just need to
stretch I'm not going to lie I need to
do something
physical work on my shoulder Mobility oh
my God okay and the lady's just
scrolling on her [__] phone she's
just standing she's just standing there
while br br while a
stranger is dressing
up the baby she's standing there
scrolling on her phone it's an elderly
woman in a wheelchair motorized vehicle
okay dressing a random baby she's never
met while the mom is on her latest
iPhone browsing Instagram you can't make
this [__] up you can't make this [__] up
some people say the future is female I
just think the future is [__]
up that
is oh
baby yeah
concern don't do that don't your life do
that baby
well bless her heart honestly that lady
who didn't even hesitate she grabbed
clothes and say she putting on that kid
bless her I also say this Walmart should
never be allowing stuff like this in
they store I know they have a hands off
policy supp you know they try not to get
involved but y'all got a kid shivering
while they in trash bags in your store
you got to call the cops but I'm going
to just take the second take the baby
away yes shout out to the lady and the
bystanders around who saw this Injustice
and acted right away right we want to
obviously focus on the person who did
the crazy thing but we should take away
from the focus about the people who saw
something bad happened in front of them
and didn't hesitate to call the cops to
put clothes on the baby that they didn't
know and immediately act in order to to
defend it so
yeah better stop and put
something
helloy how old man
what a well behaved kid too like wa wait
wait wait wait what a well behaved kid
too not crying not saying nothing
accepting everyone's Grace like at that
age a lot of them kids are super
volatile often times very scared strange
the kids just
like he's too cold to
understand that kid's been through stuff
yep that kid been through stuff a lot of
[__] yo that kid has been through a lot
or that kid or that kid has been crying
and mama don't care so he knows that
crying doesn't do anything that's not a
bad tip to ignore the kid when they're
crying because I'm not trying to do with
no cry I'm not saying no but that's
that's a bit [__] up sorry that's a
bit [__]
up for those of you who are asking for
update um yes she did go to
jail yes we did call the police I mean
why wouldn't
we why wouldn't we that's a crazy ass
question to ask
when you see a child that's being
neglected don't have on any clothes just
a diaper no shoes no socks no shirt no
nothing so why wouldn't we call the
[__]
police why wouldn't
we a know
I'm just going to ignore the hate and
I'm going to
ignore the crazy
comments I'm not going to respond to
y'all oh hell no you tell me this girl
got hait for what she did of course
there's always you know there's always
going to be someone that's going to be
talking
mind all your people want to be is talk
about uh staying on business I stay on
business then y'all going to watch a
child be neglected in front of you not
not staying on business yeah cool story
bro a lot of them a lot of them are
going to say that well I've seen some
comments too A lot of them saying that
oh yeah well you shouldn't be calling
cops on a black person
you you shouldn't be doing this you
shouldn't be that doing that you calling
you all Child Services is the worst and
this and that and blah blah blah blah
blah blah yep they've been commenting
that and there's always going to be a
[__] that's going to have
something to say that's that makes no
goddamn sense you see it in our comments
you see it in our comments when we
explain our our point of view very
clearly there's always some DB
[__] in the comments is going to
say some dumb [__] and that's the reason
why you create you created the pin of
Shame well in this is no different than
any other cases I'm calling cops of
course I'm calling the cops come call
the cops I'm calling the cops from
another phone too [__] you well talking
about oh call CLS on
black so what you're going to ignore the
fact that a black child is being abused
so you can protect some black older
woman who doesn't give [__] about the
kid that she brought into this world
voluntarily nah your logic is ass
backwards anybody who would sit by and
think it's fine to not do anything you
think it's enough to just clothe that
child you going to let him have another
running with that mom who's completely
doesn't give a [__] about his wellbeing
nah call the cop take that kid away call
the cops take that kid away that kid was
shivering and she was moving through the
Frozen Island was like she didn't give a
nah call the cops leave your kid in your
car while you go inside the store and
it's hot call the cops and everybody had
a Cod on in this in in everybody had a
Cod so it's not even it's not even the
cold aisle thing it's cold outside it's
cold it's cold outside they got that
that kid in a trash bag yeah yo have
that woman in a trash bag next she got
to spend maximum amount of dat that that
should be part of a prison sentence with
a flip phone and a trash bag for
close I like the fact that part of the
sentence is the flip phone I appreciate
that yeah yeah no iPhone no iPhone cuz I
feel like that's actually going to be
the most painful part for a lot of these
people in 2024 not having access to the
latest tech I think that's literally
going to be the worst part for them oh
not even the no it's not going to be the
fact that they take away the no it's
going to be the flip phone you have to
choose to tell people you have to choose
between having a flip phone and wearing
trash bags for the next month they going
to choose
trash
back yep that's how backwards these
people are she asked me did I have a
child in the video yes I do have a child
he's
deceased but if my child was
living God bless this woman God bless
this
woman but if my child was living my
ain't no way in hell my child will be
out
there with no clothes on just a diaper
so there you have
it the first comment do y'all know what
CPS does to kids I told you I told you
know what I know CPS doesn't do put them
in a trash bag and parade them around
the Frozen AIS I I'll never understand
that you know some parents bring a kid
into this world only to treat them like
garbage and I'm like you could have just
used a condom you could have used birth
control and just been a miserable ass
person by yourself but you brought this
person here and you going to sit there
while you fully clothed and your child
is suffering how is that ever the
logical sequence that should fck what
you mean it should be your kid that
thriving before you do it should be your
kid eating before you do but some of you
are so [__] disgusting you bring a a
person who can't care for themselves and
then you going to put yourself first mhm
instead of wrapping their kids in a
garbage bag they should have wrapped
their dick in the latex to me it's the
self-absorbed nature of being on your
phone while your child is sh
and you walking through these Frozen a
not giving a [__] that visual to me it's
crazy that's crazy dude very
upsetting at any rate is anything else
no all right if you guys want we got a
Discord and a patreon with exclusive
content we also got a Reddit that's
popping so that's where we got this
topic from that's where we're going to
get more let us know what you guys s in
the com